he is running a shadow campaign even
people in his own party are saying that
how about somebody saying saying
something a lot of people are saying
maybe Plan B is Gavin Nome you are going
to sit across from Gavin Nome a week
from this Thursday uh with the big
debate against Shan Hannity I know in
your head you would like to be the
nominee on the Republican side Gavin
Nome you know he wants to be the
Democrat is this a preview of 2024
in your dream sequence look he is he he
is running a shadow campaign even people
in his own party are saying that uh a
lot of Democrats want to move Biden out
uh and so you know you could have Harris
you could have new you could have a lot
of different people but I think it's
important that Republican voters uh get
get uh get the sense that that we may
not be running against Biden I think
it's worth noting and the reason I
wanted to do all that before
Thanksgiving is because we are all going
to sit down at a table tomorrow with
family family and friends and and
newcomers and everything else and
politics you know it just sits there
these days it's just there whether you
think it's there or not everything has
become political that's one of the
problems in our society and you're going
to sit there with people that are going
to tell you Joe Biden's just fine
they're going to tell you the Democrats
are great they're going to all of the
nonsense and you should just be able to
cleanly talk to people and tell them the
truth and bantis is consistently good at
that and you should be able to tell your
relatives and the other people sitting
across the table from you do you really
think it's Joe Biden do you really think
he's running the show right now do you
really think he has the stamina to be
president and if if you don't think that
like do you want Camala Harris to be
president or do you want Gavin Nome to
be president and what is it that you
really think is so evil about
Republicans do you really think like Joe
Scarboro that Donald Trump is a fascist
and a racist and a Nazi and he forgot to
do all of that stuff the first first
time around do you really think that all
the awful things they say about Ronda
santz are true and of the State of
Florida and all that like whether you
want to or not cuz I know most people
especially now because politics has
gotten so crazy people want to not be
involved in politics when it comes to to
sitting down with family and I'm I am
that way too I absolutely have that in
me too but if we can't work these things
out with the very people that you break
bred with on the day that you're
supposed to be thankful for all of our
freedoms then in some ways we've kind of
lost game already so
uh